one of the first films to come out of
the social distancing era of the
pandemic was How It Ends as the title
implies the film is a comedy about the
end of the world but rather than fully
embracing the medical threat of the
covid-19 pandemic the virus was swapped
for a meteor headed toward Earth While
most of the smallscale movies made
during this first phase of the pandemic
kept their casts as Tiny as possible for
practical reasons How It Ends was packed
with a slew of stars including Helen
Hunt it never aimed to anything more
than a bit of harmless fun during a
trying time for the industry and the
film didn't have much of a shelf life
beyond the era in which it was made
what's more the film's lackluster Legacy
was surely cemented by the release of
don't look up a much higher budget movie
with an almost identical concept that
came out the very same year